our relationship to Fitness is broken
don't look for Perfection look for
steady gradual progress look at what
you're doing within the environment and
try and make small changes within it
rather than add too much to your day
don't do it because someone else is
doing it do it because you want to do it
it's something you can choose to do to
really powerfully influence your mental
health
[Music]
to move is to be human it is something
that is inherent to our nature it's not
a chore it's not a box to tick or an
obligation movement is what our bodies
are designed to do we're born to move
we're born to explore and to physically
connect with the world around us in
whatever capacity we can create the joy
first
and everything else will follow movement
can be playful it can be deeply
enjoyable and even meditative So today
we're gonna dive into those benefits as
well as the hows and the whys of all
things movement in today's Master Class
the eighth in our ongoing deep dives
into the RRP Cannon where you're going
to learn how to start a movement
practice the importance of Mobility
exercises proper running and walking
techniques mental tricks to stay
motivated and how to set and achieve
your movement goals My Hope Is that this
episode gives you both the inspiration
as well as the tools to begin or improve
upon a practice that feels natural to
you that brings you Joy and that ends up
transforming your life as You Follow
That Journey this episode is brought to
you by Roca
Fitness does not have to be about
six-pack abs perfect pictures weight
loss over training or destroying your
body for the sake of some impossible
standard Fitness can be more about
listening to your body and moving in a
way that's pressure free that's positive
and and fun and this is the perspective
of Sadie Lincoln Sadie is the founder
and CEO of bar three which is a fitness
company focused not on weight loss but
rather on body positivity and personal
empowerment in the following clip you'll
hear Sadie explain why she decided to
redefine the word Fitness and how she
thinks about it now
my husband and I co-founded part three
in 2008 is when we opened I've been in
the fitness industry my entire
professional career I fell in love with
it in the 80s like meeting Jane Fonda in
my living room with my mom
it just drew me in right away for
various reasons
and when we opened bar three we didn't
use the word Fitness because I had it
anchored to negativity
and being a chore
and something that I didn't identify
with and it wasn't until about eight
years ago or
um eight years in that I took we took
back that word Fitness and we're
redefining it so what is that
redefinition and first of all I want to
point out there's nothing wrong with
Fitness as we all know it it's just it
my relationship to Fitness is broken
right and so I needed to redefine it and
and I I noticed that a lot of other
people do as well I just wasn't happy in
my own body during that era and I was
not identifying with Fitness the product
that we were selling and I had a lot of
Shame around it explain that
I'm sitting in meetings with all these
people learning about these crazy
numbers and a crazy growth of our
company I'm also learning from all these
um amazing consulting firms and the
statistics and data that our health is
on the decline so as the industry is
booming our health is declining
significantly
and so that's confusing right I'm I'm
always like obese diabetes obesity when
Fitness as a product and service was
invented in my mind 1980. obesity has
doubled since 1980. the health club
industry has uh upper right corner upper
right corner year over year it's a 30
billion dollar industry what is not
working here
Fitness is working
Fitness when you study it in a lab
you've studied it in your body
I have to it works Fitness is not broken
Fitness is good
what I have discovered is that our
relationship to Fitness is broken and
there is so much shame in that
relationship
how predominantly to this day fitness is
sold
is that you start and end the before
picture and then you do the the products
and services in a certain order and you
become the after picture that's how it's
sold
there let's look at that for a second
the before and after
that if you think about an after that's
in the future it's imagined it's not
real there's nothing real about the
after picture and literally when you see
a before and after picture which still
is prolific and that's what sells
um it's someone else
and how they how they've achieved a
physical measure of success sometimes
there's a diarrhea behind it that's like
how I feel as well but it's often a
physical manifestation so we can't ever
get to that person and by the way that
person's not that person anymore either
there is no presence yeah in the before
and after picture there is no presence
in that
and there's a shame in that so Fitness
has been sold on
you are not whole yet if you do these
things you'll be better
and and every year there's a new idea
and a new fad and a new product and a
new supplement and on top of it there's
this extreme nature of Fitness this more
extreme you go the better results you'll
get so I always think of like there's
comfort zone where you're in the center
in your comfort then there's Brave space
where you go just outside of that
comfort and that's where in the body
like you're lifting you're lifting
weights let's say in your body goes to
fatigue and failure and then it rebuilds
that's Brave space you're rebuilding
your muscle same with our mental
capacity just going just enough so that
you're rebuilding building resilience
building strength and we do need that
sand in the Oyster to make the Pearl we
need that rub in our bodies physically
but the industry goes so extreme that we
go into Panic zone so many people enter
exercise and they go
heart too hard they get injured they
anchor it to pain to shame to not
looking apart and then we get promised
in one sweat sesh you're gonna be skinny
and beautiful and perfect and awesome
right so there's just so many ridiculous
when we all talk about this we're always
like that's so ridiculous I know better
I know better
but the world says that all the time
right intellectually we know better but
emotionally we don't right so and we've
been we it it they we it plays into that
thing if I want to belong if I look that
way I'll be attractive yeah I'll be
successful I'll be seen as successful
I'll be worthy I'll be happy I'll belong
and what if this is the question we all
ask ourselves all the time what if we
exercised to practice
being honest in our bodies forget about
even like feeling good in our bodies
just honest and that everything I do in
that moment is about honoring who I am
in my physical self and what I need in
that moment the word Fitness in and of
itself is is strange because
part of it is it's aspirational but it's
also this pejorative you think of
fitness and you think about a treadmill
and you know underneath the fluorescent
light yeah and you think about a bunch
of people walking around that look
better than you and you're feeling less
than
um the whole that whole industry is
built upon preying on people's
insecurities to get you to join and then
not actually attend so they can over
subscribe you know spot on yeah
um and that's broken and not healthy and
it works it makes money of course and
if you look at Fitness as an analogy I I
just over and over again what we teach
in the in our room at bar three is such
an analogy of life we there's 60 Minutes
of moving together as a group and
aligning our body with intention
Foundation lining the body up getting
into posture in a in a way that with
Integrity but the real work is looking
inside and figuring out what do I need
right now and then honoring that and
moving in a way and taking shape in your
body in a way that's right for what you
need
when you're in a group the expectation
is that you're looking outside yourself
and you're copying what everybody else
is doing on top of these conditions that
full plank on the floor is harder so
it's better and it's going to get me
where I need to be so I need to do full
plank but if you're doing full Plank and
you have like burning wrist pain maybe
plank is better at the ballet bar
and if you stand up at the ballet bar
and everybody's at the on the floor
that's literally and figuratively a
practice of standing up for yourself and
honoring what your body needs
and honoring your values like I'm body
wisdom taking care of my body and not
disassociating with it and trying to
fight through it
and that's what I think the real work is
is practicing that over and over and
over again
um I think I I also read that you open
the class by saying you know we're going
to take you through this hour-long
experience and I'm gonna say a lot of
things or the instructor is going to say
a lot of things but the most important
thing is that you listen to yourself
right like you kind of set that tone
that that provides that like kernel of
empowerment for the individual because
we need to practice that we all know
that we all know when we sit quietly
there's those moments you know your
inner self your inner knowing is is
important you're not just exercising
your muscles joint Mobility posture
connection
endurance you're not just exercising
that you're exercising so much more yeah
um and that is when we do all three of
those things I think of it as physical
exercise connectedness mental exercise
connectedness and the third that's
really important is social connectedness
exercising social connectedness the
reason we're exercising is to
acknowledge oh I'm doing it like
everybody else I should be doing it like
myself instead of trying to copy and
Skip's understanding that's one of my
favorite quotes I read that in a book
rework copying skips understanding and
movement is an exercise of exercising
body wisdom of learning about your body
that's why I love it now I have my
attachment to that versus it being a
chore shame I'm not good enough my
injury is something I should push away
instead of work with
I think I'm interpreted often as oh
that's soft and sweet and my and it
doesn't mean that it's not hard work
yeah like all of what I'm talking about
I think has a lot to do with being an
endurance athlete for example there's
nothing wrong with wanting to win yeah
there's nothing wrong with the results
and the pain and like the the resilience
and the grit and the pushing through and
the healing the heart that that hard
work right
um and like I just think that every one
of us can practice that in a different
way and that there's just there's not
one way to do that but it's always brief
space that when I was talking about
Brave space my favorite quote is the
sand and the oyster that makes the Pearl
the rub
and so like with bar three it is
challenging you do go to fatigue it does
it is a struggle and then it's learning
to breathe through that struggle and and
look at it without judgment or shame
and then work all the way through it
for a lot of people the word exercise
too often conjures unpleasant images of
intense workouts treadmills and stair
Masters and as Sadie said calorie
burning that's based on judgment and
shame and so it's no wonder that a lot
of people find it difficult to even get
started let alone maintain a sustained
movement practice but health
psychologist and Stanford University
lecturer Kelly McGonagall believes
there's a feel-good form of movement
meant for everybody and she's here to
help you find it
you think you don't like to move you
think you don't enjoy it I believe that
there's a form of movement meant for
everyone and no matter what body you're
in or no matter what your past
experience is there's probably a way
that moving your body will give you
access to something that you want
whether it's social connection or hope a
different sense of yourself
what is the feeling that I have when I
Marvel about how the body is so um is is
almost designed to help us find
happiness and meaning through movement
what's that feeling that sense of wonder
and awe and what does it tell us about
being human
and when I had permission to think in
that way I feel like it opened me up to
a different type of story as well when I
started talking to people about movement
one of the things I realized is when you
talk to people who have found meaning in
movement that they become this version
of themselves when they're telling you
their story that is this amazing mixture
of both incredible vulnerability
and strength that somehow they both
emerge and you can see like this full
human in this tremendous glory and
beauty and I felt like
um I need to do that Justice I came
across this paper I think it was maybe a
2016 paper where the scientists talk
about this research and they just sort
of throw out the term hope molecules and
I remember circling it I think I like
said to my husband oh my gosh you're not
going to believe this term it
encapsulates so much about why movement
is amazing and I feel like nobody else
is using this term it's just in this one
paper I'm sure the scientists have used
it again but uh let me explain what it
is so this is the idea that our muscles
are like an endocrine organ and that
when you contract your muscles in any
type of movement they are secreting
chemicals into your bloodstream that are
really good for every system of your
body I mean they're great for your heart
health and your immune function and some
of them can kill cancer cells you know
all the stuff we know exercise is good
for
that a big part of these these proteins
and chemicals that are being released by
your muscles which are called myokines
they have profound effects on the brain
so you go for a walk or a run or you
lift weights and your muscles contract
and they secrete these proteins into
your bloodstream they travel to your
brain they cross the blood-brain barrier
and in your brain they can act as an
antidepressant like irisin can they can
make your brain more resilient to stress
they increase motivation they help you
learn from experience and the only way
you get these chemicals is by using your
muscles it's like this is part of how we
become our best selves is we have to use
our muscles and then the scientists call
them hope molecules because in this one
study they found that exercise could
protect rodents from experiencing
depression and post-traumatic stress
disorder if you severely traumatize them
so this idea that that these molecules
are giving you hope even in very
difficult times so it's not and they
human this is that's right it's not
innately humans so extrapolating on that
idea like what do you like what do you
make of that like what does that mean
well first of all a very practical level
it means when I go for a walk or I
exercise I will literally say to myself
you're giving yourself an intravenous
dose of Hope like I think this is how we
should frame movement that that it's
something you can choose to do to really
powerfully influence your mental health
um and your resilience and every time
you move you're doing that I think to
know that to like look at your own
muscles and be able to say thank you
legs you're tired now that was hard work
but like legs you're you are a pharmacy
that of antidepressants and resilience
and hope
um then sort of thinking like in a more
philosophical way
again one of the things that I feel like
the anthropology and the science is
pointing to is that movement is how your
brain knows you are alive and engaged in
life and when you move on a regular
basis your brain basically says I guess
we have to be the best version of
ourselves because we're in this thing
called life and so you know you
mentioned some other things too like
when you exercise you see increased
levels of neurotransmitters that tend to
increase our willingness to cooperate
and the pleasure we get from connecting
with others that give us hope and
courage I mean even that lactic acid
that that metabolic byproduct of
exercise that lactic acid seems to have
an anti-anxiety and antidepressant
effect this is like crazy stuff it's not
just an endorphin rash it's like at
every level of our biology when we move
our our brain is like I guess we we have
to do this thing called life and so you
know for people like me who've struggled
with anxiety or depression this idea
that you can convince your brain to want
to fully engage with life in a brave way
or in a hopeful way through movement is
so phenomenal but I think there's a lot
of people out there who who can read the
book or listen to what you're saying and
they you know they can intellectually
grasp the all the finer points of why
this is a good idea but they lack that
impetus like they look at it as
burdensome or or intimidating or
something that they just don't connect
with right so a couple things about this
first of all I should say in in my
experience talking to people there are a
lot of late to life movers who just need
to define the right form of movement and
I don't think we get exposed to enough
diversity of movement like women who got
in a boat to row and had their whole
life thought they had the wrong body
type that they weren't athletes but
suddenly they got in a boat with other
women and were rowing and they were like
yes my body was born for this
um that you know there's so many forms
of movement that change the way you feel
about yourself because
they they just create a different
narrative about who you are I talk to so
many women who discovered things like
power lifting or CrossFit or ax throwing
we're suddenly they were doing these
amazing things with their bodies and
they felt powerful and uh it was a side
of themselves they'd never experienced
before
and if you were to only like listen to
the way that the media usually talks
about exercise it's all about burning
calories right it's all about what you
look like and you can get pulled into
places where instead of being told like
this is what it feels like to stand in
your own strength you're told now you're
burning more calories so you won't look
as hideous as you looked walking in
today I mean like that is a very
different experience and too often
people's movement experiences have been
defined by this obsession with burning
calories and improving your appearance
and making yourself more acceptable to
either yourself or the Judgment of
society and it gets very confusing very
quickly and so I'm always encouraging
people
like what's the form of movement if
someone were to send you a YouTube video
what's a video you would watch and be
like wow that's amazing and like what's
the version of that that would fit into
your life who's doing that in a way
that's appropriate for the body you have
right now or the you know who you want
to become that it's not about like
getting a Tracker that's going to tell
you if you've done enough yet right
there's so much that gets in the way of
finding the movement that will make you
happy that can make it feel like a chore
like a punishment we have such a limited
perspective on what those options are we
just think about the gym and the
StairMaster machine and the little LED
readout that tells you calories and time
and while you're watching you know the
news and it's just
it's okay to distract yourself while
you're exercising if that works for you
but there are a lot of forms of movement
where the more attention you pay to what
you're doing actually the more
pleasurable it is but often I think the
advice we get is just get on the
treadmill and watch you know Netflix so
that you're not really there and you can
get through it but I bet there's some
form of movement where if you were
really there you would have an amazing
experience a sense of yourself or a
connection with others
Kelly's perspective is quite similar to
advice I give all the time for anyone
struggling to stay motivated at a given
exercise the fix is always to follow
your curiosity and to follow your joy
you don't want to go for a run fine go
play Pickleball with some friends the
point is just to remain active because a
sedentary lifestyle can lead to
everything from poor posture back and
neck pain limited range of motion muscle
atrophy and even an increased risk of
chronic lifestyle disease this is why
movement especially specifically
movements that focus on Mobility
stability and range of motion are so
important to our physical and mental
health so in this next clip Mobility
Wizards Kelly and Juliet Starrett teach
us the basics of Mobility maintenance
and how to pursue the sports and
exercises you love injury for free
throughout your life
Mobility is is really the ability to be
able to move freely through your
environment and do the things you want
to be able to do with your body whatever
those things may be now we we offer a
lot of tools which we call mobilizations
which are things you can do to help
improve your mobility and range of
motion but you know to us at the highest
level it's a it's the ability to move
freely ideally without pain or at least
minimizing pain and feel to do the
things you love to do we could also
Define mobility as do you have your
native range of motion and can you
control that native range of motion so
are you a skilled person and what Juliet
said is all of that is important but
really what is it you want to do in your
world and environment and how do you
want to express this body that's the
most important thing and I think that's
where we got in the weeds you know yeah
hip range of motion is important yeah
yeah but if it prevents you from doing
something or you're having pain and
that's also conjoined with the fact that
you don't have access to that range
maybe that's the reason you should care
well I'm like let me just give you one
example like if you just asked anyone on
the street like do you care about your
hip range of motion they're going to be
like no why would I care about that
um but but as an example we were
recently talking to a friend of ours who
has a four-month-old baby and has both
sets of parents visiting and their his
parents are like in their mid-60s so um
you know not that much older than us and
they uh his mother is able to get up off
get up and down off the ground and sit
with the baby but his mother-in-law
can't get down onto the ground or up off
of the ground and so can't sit on the
floor and play with the grandchild and
that's one of those things that you
don't think about until it's it's like a
use it or lose it kind of thing but like
that right there is hip range of motion
so you may not care athletically about
hip range of motion because you're not
trying to run faster or lift more
weights or you know whatever an athlete
might need to care about hip range of
motion for but you know most people
would say man D you know do you want to
be able to sit on the floor and play
with your grandchild when you have one
and they'd be like yes I do you
um and so you know that's one of the
reasons why people should care about
their hip brain's range of motion a lot
of people are confused about what a good
foundational practice looks like and we
should be able to take those lessons and
actually say hey look we understand that
you're not an elite athlete but you're
just a you know just a middle-aged dad
who wants to stay up with this local
mountain bike club that's me and what
are the ways where I can do that in the
context of my busy life so I don't have
to you know throw everything away and I
think that's a that really
is an opportunity for us to make sense
of all of the you know bright people
working in this high performance world
I'm sure you've heard of Chris Hinshaw's
old man balance test uh where you put
your shoes on on one oh this is great
everyone you're welcome everyone
listening should do this test you stand
called again it's called the oh Chris
Hinshaw
um and it's called The Old Man balance
test and he actually created it um so
that he would have something to compete
against his kids and win and so uh the
idea is you put your socks and shoes on
the floor and you stand on one leg and
you reach down and grab your sock and
you put on your sock without putting
that foot down and then you reach down
and grab your shoe and put your shoe on
and tie it and then you switch and do it
on the other side and it's a really
great two minute balance practice and
that's how I put my shoes on every
single day you know and that's something
that's just this little you know small
behavior that that we add into our day
that's easy and fun and you can you know
challenge your kids to do it and so you
know that's just one of those things
that we've snuck in and said hey there
are ways that you can change your
environment and just slightly think
about your environment differently so
that these are just things you do
without having to rely on Willpower or
motivation so if you in the evening
could sit down next to a ball a tennis
ball a softball roller and ask yourself
from the day what store what hurts
what's achy and I'm going to commit 10
minutes the first part of this show I'm
watching I'm just going to roll around
on whatever
ails me that's a really important
conversation you could begin to have I'm
talking about 10 minutes like that's
super reasonable and the reason we
started shifting that to the day from
the day and the gym to the evening was
that we saw that people didn't actually
do it or want to do it as a team but in
the evening they had time and agency and
nothing was happening at the end of the
day like you're on Facebook you're
you're surfing Instagram so there was
this great moment where you could do
some some self-care and 10 minutes a
night usually turns into 12 to 14
minutes because you discover something
you can sit on your coffee table put
that ball right in your hamstrings just
roll around then the next sort of level
there is we could say hey can you take a
full breath in that position so if
you're working on something or you've
got some aspect of your body that hurts
and you push on it and that takes your
breath away or you catch your breath
then we found an area of Interest it
doesn't mean we need to shy away from
that it's okay that that's uncomfortable
to compression so one of the first
things we can do is say am I doing hurt
harm to myself no not at all you can if
you can take a full breath in and out
you're signaling to your brain this is
safe nerves are king of the breath the
breath is King of the brain that's iang
our 101. and why breathing is such an
important part of yoga is teaching your
body to accept and be able to control
those positions by breathing there your
brain says it's not a threat so if you
find a painful spot or a sore spot or an
uncomfortable spot you found a spot and
all you need to do is take a four second
inhale there
contract into the ball roller and hold
that for four seconds we call that an
isometric in the in the parlance right
you're just building a tension or a
movement without Motion in the limb and
then exhale a long time for eight
seconds long exhale and what you'll find
is if you just repeat that cycle a few
times whatever hurts in that area that
you're working sometimes starts to hurt
less you're desensitizing you're
changing your some threat resetting some
threat signals and if you started doing
that on your back your hips your calves
your feet what you can realize is wow I
can make myself feel better and because
you did it before you bed it's like
getting a massage you tend to sleep a
little bit you're down regulating yeah
and We snuck in breath practice and you
had to get up and down off the
groundwork you ruined it yeah exactly
right that's exactly right one of the
things we know is that pain doesn't mean
injury it doesn't even mean tissue
trauma or damage it's a request for
change so part of what we're trying to
say in this book is hey we can try to
treat pain and use it just as another
metric like if you were stiff this
morning because you're a big workout
yesterday you're not thinking you know
you've got you know
some you know you didn't contract rabies
you just are sore right right from your
run and so if we can shift that
narrative a little bit and then also
Empower people that hey there's a whole
lot they can do and some of that is
sleep and some of that is nutrition and
some of that is is down regulation but
all a lot of it is there's some inputs
you can do that are really safe and
really easy and then we can have the
next conversation your range of motion
doesn't have to change because you age
that's the one physical you're going to
be less powerful you may be able to
maintain your aerobic power for a long
time we know that that to be true but
your ability to express your range of
motion in your joints doesn't have to
degrade necessarily you may have bony
blocks and a patina of athleticism work
through the fascia and all right but
we're as we take the systems approach
you being able to get up and down off
the ground or flex your knee all the way
doesn't have to go away and I think that
that's important to remember to consider
for people like
today by Roca glasses are not something
you normally think about as a piece of
performance gear which when you think
about it is kind of insane because you
can't perform at your best if you can't
see well the Geniuses at Roka basically
rebuilt eyewear from the ground up no
matter how active you are or how much
you sweat these things never slip or
fall off your face they're super durable
they look awesome and they've got tons
of super classy modern styles to choose
from I've been rocking rokas for about
four years at this point I love them I'm
a big fan of the Hamilton style and
gloss black that's this Frame right here
as well as clear or I guess they call
them vintage on the website and if you
want to try them out for yourself you
can do that right now and unlock 20 off
your order with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
[Music]
as we age we don't have to sacrifice our
Mobility or range of motion there are
practices we can adopt now that can
secure our ability to stay fit and
active well into our 70s 80s 90s and
Beyond and few people embody this ethos
more powerfully than Chef Babette who
believes that caring for our bodies is
an act of self-love a bet is a vegan
Superstar and the very model of fit and
radiant at 72 years young listen
carefully as she shares the importance
of taking care of ourselves as we age
how to form an easy and impactful
routine and the power of starting a new
lifestyle with one simple movement at a
time
part of the whole self-loving thing is
to be a part of all of this to be able
to move you know if if if I want to run
a shield I can run a hill I don't want
to have a Life Alert I don't I don't
want to get in the bathtub and can't get
out so I force myself to take baths
sometimes I'm not always taking showers
make sure you get your butt out the tub
uh yeah but that's the whole thing when
you get older it's all about like if you
fall down and you can't and you can't
get that that's what people need to
really understand now of course
sometimes we have accidents that you
know is not any fault of our own but uh
when we just sit down and just let it go
that's generally what will happen to you
lose strength and another thing that I I
think
is I'm not a superficial person I am I
enjoy the aging process I don't look
like I looked when I was 60. you know
what I mean but
however it is however this look is going
to be as I age I embrace it because just
think I had lived an entire lifetime
looking different so you know what I
mean it's not a bad thing to have the
the crow's feet I I don't I don't care
to use anything to get rid of that I'm
okay with it I want to see what it's
going to be I saw one of the most
beautiful women I've ever seen before
she weared lines like in this table but
she was beautiful
she was beautiful and if just to it she
owned it and she she's comfortable with
who she is and yeah oh she was just
gorgeous and that is how we should all
be because it's each step of the journey
that we embrace
and appreciate and don't you know I
can't I can't wear that I can't wear the
bushy eyelash it's gonna be a little bit
too over that that don't work on this
face
but you did when you turned 70 you
posted these you did like a bathing suit
all right remember bananas like when
everybody was sharing that and it went
crazy that one went that was another
like inflection point in your your your
kind of story arc right yeah people
really really love that I got a little
bold the next year and did bikinis and
stuff but this year I am going to do uh
a beautiful
um
um photo of myself but um you'll see
It'll be but no more bathing suit so I'm
good for that I still have my little
calendars I wasn't able to give them all
away and now it's the end of the year
you made like a bathing suit calendar
and yes I should have brought you one
hang it up over here oh man we got to
get you one we gotta get you one but the
fitness routine that's basically like
strength training that's everything
you're in the gym
and some hiking or stairs you like to do
the stairs and stuff like that but it's
pretty fast I had a torn growing so I
hadn't been really doing too much of the
hype because
um I'm a part of a docu-series in
Houston Texas and um
yeah so we were we I was feeling good
from the grad I didn't feel like I still
had the tear
and we went to the track we got to the
track sister was sprinting and I was
like yeah I feel really good so I got up
there and and all the athletes
um were like no no Chef you haven't
stretched you haven't I got out there
and I
by the time I got to the end I had to
limp back yeah you know how grow on tear
will do it takes a long time a long time
a long time yeah so we've been very
careful my trainer and I going forward
not to stretch that too much and I
stairs I love stairs and you know I love
running heels I just posted a video when
we were in Saint Martin of me hitting
the hill
um I just love movement I love knowing
that I can move I love that I I I've
often thought if something ever happened
and I was the only person that could get
to help
even at my age I know I'm in shape
enough to do that right that's
maintaining that is so key especially as
you get older consistency yeah like the
gym stuff becomes really important I I
started with one push-up
and every day
I would add a push-up
and uh if I couldn't add a push-up I do
the numbers that I'd done the day before
but I tell people that I tell women that
start with one inch by inch Life's a
cinch yeah whether it's push-ups or
anything anything that's that's the way
you do anything yeah it's by starting
with one starting with one like I have
to do at least 72 push-ups on my
birthday
so I'm gonna do it in the restaurant
anybody that wants to come to the
restaurant and hang out and either get
down there and do some push-ups with me
maybe I'll give you a taco
this is why you can't hire somebody to
help you in the restaurant you're giving
away too much stuff that's my husband
you suck like
but but I figured like this if somebody
suggested to me because I was doing set
to 25 and someone said you know I I can
do that many but I do sets of ten and
then I thought that's a lot easier
because the the the time between sets is
only like a minute or two versus three
to four minutes when I'm doing set to
25. so I'm gonna do sets of ten I might
even get push out a hundred honey yeah
well if you break it down into sets of
ten then it's easier to build exactly
exactly yeah yeah so there you go
to be clear the goal shouldn't be to
live as long as possible it should be to
live as vibrantly and with maximum
Mobility for as long as possible this is
longevity Overlord Dr Peter Attias
scientific Obsession and in this next
clip Peter continues on this theme of
maintaining Mobility as we age by
sharing movement practices one can adopt
now to live stronger and more agile for
longer he also explains the function and
importance of dynamic neuromuscular
stabilization muscle recruitment how to
identify and unlearn poor movement
patterns and how to be a lifelong
athlete
you'd be amazed at how many people even
in their 40s and 50s don't possess even
though they're strong enough to meet the
metrics of their 90 year old self they
already show signs of weakness in terms
of
instability in their hips instability in
their knees horrible patterns of walking
um you know pelvic tilts that are too
far forward all of these things that
they can sort of muscle their way
through when they're younger but it
becomes problematic later athletes are
the best cheaters
right the more you're you're a grinder
the better you are at cheating your way
around bad movement patterns right and
and so the downstream implications of
that become cataclysmic yeah you have to
start to unlearn that stuff so that's
what began for me in
2018 I mean and you know how it
presented actually was I was getting
tennis elbow
and I'm like it's really odd because I
don't play tennis so that doesn't seem
like a likely injury
um and that that's when I first met a
guy who kind of got me on this path
using something called Dynamic
neuromuscular stabilization and he
watched me do pull-ups he's like let me
see you do a pull-up and I was like dude
I own this baby watch you know did a
million Pull-Ups for him and he's like
yeah it's horrible like your Technique
is so bad you have no scapular control
whatsoever you are transmitting so much
force into your elbows doing that
because you can't keep your scapula in
place
there is a fundamental difference
between having a strong muscle
and knowing how to recruit it and for me
the aha moment came with my hamstrings I
have always prided myself in having just
the strongest legs right I mean you know
cyclists have strong legs I deadlift
tons of weight I do Insane amounts of
stupid leg curls all every you name it
I'll do it but when I was placed on the
floor in a very simple position laying
on your back knees bent feet flat on the
floor could I without screwing around in
my pelvis just pull back with my feet a
pure hamstring recruitment no could not
yeah I can't do that either yeah
couldn't do it yeah and and so what that
says is it doesn't actually matter how
strong your hamstrings are you can't
recruit them and if you can't recruit
them your pelvis is tilted forward you
have to be able to keep those hamstrings
recruited to keep that pelvis in the
right position
I mean it took me a year of daily I mean
just grinding away at these movements in
this practice and now
it's hard for me to remember what it was
like to not be able to recruit my
hamstring so it can you can unlearn
these patterns But the irony of it is
the more of an athletic background you
have the longer it will actually take
you to unlearn because you have more bad
stuff than neural pathways are so
they're so they're so wired the good
news is you have
you have the you have the you have the
Reps on how to do stuff so I think it's
a wash taking an untrained person and
teaching them versus taking a highly
trained person and teaching them takes
about the same amount of time but for
different reasons one of the things that
you've talked about quite a bit is is
noticing how natural it is for your
children to do all of these movements
that then become so difficult
uh for us as adults because we've
unlearned them in our sedentary
Lifestyles kind of detach us from you
know our our kind of natural blueprint
and ability to do those things so you
know how can we you know as as most
people listening or watching this
probably have to sit in a chair for
their work and we're sitting in chairs
right now what are some of the practices
that could be adopted to you know help
keep us connected to that natural
ability that is kind of innate in our
unconscious I mean for me I've taken a
very deliberate approach to that so four
or five years ago when I got introduced
to this pattern of movement called
Dynamic neuromuscular statistics that's
super interesting having now been
connected to a number of these
practitioners I I have found this to be
one of the most important systems that
I've Incorporated so initially my
exposure to it was basically to fix
problems right I was fixed I had two
nagging issues four or five years ago
one was this uh elbow issue which again
I couldn't understand what it was
causing it until I realized it was
inability to localize my and control my
scapula and the other was just my right
s i joint nagged you know we just had
this little nagging pain in the right SI
joint not certainly didn't ever raise to
the level of lower back pain no sciatica
nothing like that but whenever I dead
lifted really really heavy
50 of that 50 of those days I would be
punished with some right SI joint pain
and again these two things seemed
completely unrelated until I got under
the hood of what was going on with my
movement patterns and I realized you
know like every whatever I was 45 year
old I didn't know how to move so
what started out as kind of rehab has
then just morphed into life movements so
I do an hour a week in person with a DNS
teacher
so a guy named Kyler Brown comes to my
house once a week we just Hammer DNS
movements together and then I'll spend
10 minutes every day doing them on my
own
and that has been kind of life-changing
um now of course with my shoulder injury
Kyler is overseeing the rehab there and
so we're now incorporating
really good shoulder rehab coupled with
the DNS principles of getting my scapula
to relearn how to move because when you
have this type of an injury and you have
surgery the the the brain really wants
to shut off how this thing works so now
we're just going to basically reprogram
right
so what is an example of a DNS movement
or the first one we're trying to
understand yeah yeah visualize it the
very first one is something called
learning how to access intra-abdominal
pressure so you know I think most people
who think about breathing have a pretty
good sense that you aren't just
breathing into your thoracic cavity
right a good breath has to have the
diaphragm going down you have to get
into the abdomen what DNS does is it
really explains to you how a child is
breathing which is
you know if you imagine the waistband of
your pants or your shorts when a child
is breathing that thing is fully
expanding so they have purely concentric
force in their abdomen with with every
breath and again if you look at a really
good power lifter or something you'll
see the same thing I mean the amount of
intra-abdominal pressure that they have
to generate to be able to move such
heavy loads is essential and so that was
literally the very first thing we worked
on is just can you access pelvic floor
pressure can you create enough pressure
into your pelvic floor can you maintain
it while you breathe so that first of
all it's just hard to do that out of the
game and the second thing is you can do
it but you're not relaxed so you have to
be able to do that hold it while you can
breathe around it
the next things for me that were very
important I have a very congenitally
narrow c-spine
and if you look at an MRI of my neck you
you just you wouldn't believe what a
disaster it looks like even though I've
never really had an issue
but I'm being very preventative about it
and so one of the other things I'm
working on is learning how to use the
Deep neck stabilizers so these are
muscles that ride on the back
um they're inside you don't see them so
they're not these scalene muscles that
are in front they're the muscles that
sit on the vertebral body sort of deep
in my neck and it's learning how to use
those muscles to keep my head forward so
I'm not relying on on these muscles here
and so that's a lot of muscle that's a
lot of movements where I'm on my back
chin is forward
using the Q of the eyes looking forward
which kind of lights up that circuit and
using various pelvic positions arm
positions and leg positions in there so
it's very subtle and gentle but it's
more about like how do I connect the you
know my intention and my mind to these
muscle groups to get them to just
activate the starting positions are now
it starts to get very elaborate
basically if you if you you know someone
Googles sort of a DNS progression you'll
see how complicated it will get because
you're basically walking through the
first two years of development so the
stuff I just described is
is like you know is the fetus basically
and you start moving into a three-month
position a four month five month six
month position where now a child is
learning how to roll well they roll in a
very connected way so when they're
reaching for something with this arm
they're completely connected across
their oblique sling and they're going to
initiate that movement and down to their
foot this is the other stuff that was
just like when I look at videos of me
four years ago and videos of me now I
just don't know what the hell I was
doing before like how I was getting away
with the nonsense of being completely
disconnected you know scapulas all over
the place and and all that sort of stuff
and here's the other thing the best
athletes in the world kind of naturally
do this that's another thing I've
learned is that there are some really
exceptional athletes out there who have
never once spent a minute learning DNS
but when you look at them they have
somehow managed to preserve those
neuromuscular Pathways and that is a
essentially a big part of what their
athletic gift is and I would imagine
it's it's pretty good for injury
prevention right if you're if you have
the ability to recruit all of these
muscle groups you're inherently more
stable and and resistant to a lot of the
injuries that are occurring from those
imbalances yeah and that's why for me
it's just it's a it's a once a week you
know do the lesson once a week you know
push push how much further can I get in
those things and and then it's a it's
it's part of what we call our dailies so
we have for our patients we program
things called dailies like this is gonna
you know whether today's a zone two day
a strength day a rest day you still have
your dailies you got your 10 minutes of
daily
so I assume there's practitioners
trained practitioners who can teach this
uh but are there YouTube videos like if
somebody's listening to this I mean how
should they go about researching this or
finding so I did a podcast with one of
the probably six or seven most prominent
teachers in the United States a guy
named Michael rentala and uh we have the
video of my interview with him and then
also a few introductory movements
probably another hour worth of videos we
made and I suspect there's got to be a
ton on YouTube
Peter mentioned how athletes get away
with not utilizing proper technique when
they're younger but as they age the
improper technique begins to cause pain
and injury Downstream and I feel this is
especially true for runners getting
started with running seems as easy as
lacing up shoes and running out the door
and and of course to some extent that
that is easy it is easy but proper
running technique is vital to avoiding
injury later in life and staying a
runner for as long as you can
Born to Run two authors Chris McDougall
and Eric Orton expand on this sentiment
by sharing leg stiffness drills Barefoot
exercises and the power of movement
snacks bite size mobility and movement
practices any athlete can adopt
this idea and you talk about it in Born
around two like don't teach people
technique when it comes to running like
everyone's an ad of one and there is no
right or wrong way and we all know how
to run so you just go out and run and
like don't mess around with that which
is insane when you deconstruct that like
you use the example of like the
basketball player like you don't just
throw the ball up in the air and hope
for the best like you it's a skill just
like anything else and there is a right
way and a wrong way and so much about
our you know modern Lifestyles and we
can get into all of that drive us into
situations where we're compelled to do
it improperly and that leads to all of
these you know injuries and persistent
you know problems that sideline people
unnecessarily you know I I tell a lot of
beginning runners
don't view starting running
as a workout or as a form of Fitness or
a way to lose weight
create the joy first
and everything else will follow and that
goes into learning to be efficient not
thinking it has to be hard and that's
that's kind of what we really dove into
with Chris is that I worked kind of the
real easy end but also he did a lot of
Hill Sprints and a lot of other higher
effort training to develop that
efficiency and economy that was you know
revelatory you know he was in a matter
of a couple weeks doing so much more
than he had ever done just be by
changing things up you know I you know
let's like let's hone in on the on the
on the form piece for a little bit I
think with with Born to Run
um it became a little bit reductive in
the sense that everyone just thought it
was about minimalism and barefoot
running and that is a piece in there for
sure right but that's really kind of
evidence of a broader uh you know
concept around form technique and and
lifestyle I think the further we get
away from the ground in a shoe the more
we are getting away from allowing our
feet to work in a natural environment
and I think what people really need to
understand is that how we use our feet
really dictate how we stabilize you know
our first line of defense as Runners is
with our big toe and our Arch that's our
stabilizer and that really dictates how
well we use our glutes
so how we use our feet directly relate
to how we've kind of hear the important
stability strength we need to be healthy
strong performance or longevity-based
Runners but for me even more so it's
it's what we're doing for the structural
system is that a lot of what's in the
book waking up all those muscles and
groupings and using them in an
appropriate manner if activating things
we we were in Lawrence Kansas what two
days ago or whatever it was and you know
kind of our Mo for these events have
been start out with some of our our
skills in the book
and then go for a run and we did some
neuromuscular jumping and and what we
call leg stiffness leg stiffness is a
crucial element for performance and
Longevity for good health and running
and so we went through our leg stiffness
exercises and then went for a trail run
and after the trail run two two gals
came up to me and they they said those
exercises were
transformed my running in a matter of 30
minutes because normally I would not be
able to run that trail as a steady run I
felt like I could run forever what does
that mean leg stiffness
essentially your ability to
land and get off the ground as quickly
as possible
helping your Cadence so I see Cadence
and leg stiffness go hand in hand for
performance and for longevity or
you know that that real feel-good we
want out of running where it takes away
tightness when we hear leg stiffness
that's a good thing it doesn't mean lack
of Mobility or tightness it's it's your
ability to use and operate the springs
and rubber bands in your body to land
and snap and get off of it as quick as
possible I see yeah cool talk about a
little bit about the movement snacks I
mean that's sort of drill oriented but I
like how you've encapsulated that and
and turned it into like a fun thing yeah
the the movement snacks are something
that you can do anytime anywhere for a
variety of reasons but how we
strategically
use them in the book is a lot of
diving into the Diagnostics of the
injury chapter where
um maybe the the movement snacks are a
strategic way to begin to add more
Mobility or
give you a sense of where you're lacking
in movement while you're then
implementing some of the the remedies
for that specific injury these are these
are developed by a friend of ours Julie
Angel who comes from a parkour
background and so what Julie Julie's
actually a filmmaker who started to film
parkour athletes and as an observer she
realized oh they've got some really kind
of cool
full natural movement skills that a lot
of people could benefit from so she
extracted movement snacks from the
isolated movements of Parkour athletes
like Precision jumping or quadrupedal
movement right around on all fours yeah
yeah but that kind of thing too to
balance on your left foot and your right
hand at the same time and move forward
and then she realized these are fun they
are non-threatening and that if you do a
little bit of bear crawl for like 30
seconds and you stand up Everything
feels loosened and so I think it's kind
of a genius move by by Julie to create
movement snacks because you take that
group of people I'm not a runner I don't
want to do this I don't do that oh yeah
so the parkour Community will form a big
circle as a way of saying hello and then
they will bear crawl to the center and
everyone will high five and then they'll
reverse and bear crawl backwards back
out that's the warm-up but they've now
extended their entire chain of motion
their arms shoulders backs are loosened
and they're ready to go out and work out
so that's what we we basically uh
adopted all these things from from
Julius and movement snacks
um cool well let's let's uh let's end
this with a couple drills things that
you can I don't know if we can like if
it's possible to articulate it in a way
where people can kind of understand but
like one or two things that people could
start to practice where they can get a
gauge on like oh this is why I feel this
way because this thing is weak or what
have you yeah so that maybe we can hit
it from two sides one what we call the
foot core where we can train our feet
we've got muscles on the bottom of our
feet and there's some simple but very
very potent ways to train your feet and
it's a simply you always kind of want to
work Barefoot and simply taking off your
shoes and socks and balancing on your
forefoot on one leg man
Chris is sick of me here and saying this
but you know you're going to feel it
where you need it you're going to the
weakest link is going to show up it
might be for someone hey they start to
feel it in the feet in the arch or it
might be the calf or hey they're strong
down there they they bike or they do
mountain running and so they're strong
down below the knee but they start to
feel it in their glue and that's that's
how the feet really affect everything up
through the leg so again simply Barefoot
forefoot balancing right I've noticed
and I don't know whether this is an age
thing or a weakness thing or whatever
but my balance got really bad like when
I you know when I stand on one leg or
I'm putting my underwear on or whatever
I'm like why am I why can't I just you
know hold myself up in a stable way and
I think too in doing these simple
um foot core exercises that you're going
to start to see or feel a difference
between right and left and then you can
start maybe making a correlation of oh
yeah I'm kind of tighter on this side
and and making a correlation of how
poorly or how well you're using each
foot based on how you're feeling as an
athlete The Genius of these exercises
that Eric came up with is I wanted
everything to be something I would
personally do and if I ain't going to do
it I'm not going to put in the book and
things like the one foot balancing if
you're waiting for the coffee to brew
you got two minutes on your hands you
can do this and that's what I really
like about them these are
extraordinarily practical
but have a great um residual effect as
well and that doesn't mean they're not
potent I mean right as you're listening
right now take off your shoes and socks
and balance on your forefoot it's it's
not an easy thing and you can see how
challenging and difficult it is and with
that
in that position regardless of good or
bad form we're asking ourselves to be in
that position every step as we run and
you need to be stable there and that's
how we can really train the fee it has
these the self-correcting part of this
is that art doesn't give you any
instructions on how you he goes just
move your arms and move your legs
however you want to get that balance
what you find is you self-correct you
realize oh if I just kind of tighten my
core up a little bit if I straighten my
posture if I do my arms like this and so
you do it for 30 seconds and your body
will find that balance that you are
struggling for just by putting itself in
that position yeah The Tweak for me is
embracing the fact that so much of that
is about like creating those neural
Pathways it's not about suffering like
you know the athlete in me is like I'm
going to do it until it hurts or how
many of these lifts you know am I gonna
do well I'll just do it until it's
burning like crazy but it's not really
about that it's really about just
developing The Habit as a preset and
that's about like your mind connecting
with that movement it's not about like
you know hitting anything hard it's the
best warm-up you can do because now
we're turning an electrical system on
before we go out and run yeah so another
one leg stiffeners we talked about is
simply there's three types of strength
we have concentric eccentric and
isometric and The Eccentric and
isometric is very rarely talked about
and especially the isometric where it's
that when we land as a runner there's a
moment in time
be after our land and before we take off
that is really really crucial for
injuries that isometric hold okay
a lot of Runners don't have that so leg
stiffener exercise would be simply
standing on your right foot barefoot
and just taking a short Leap Forward and
sticking it like a ballerina
without a whole lot of leg movement you
want to stick it without movement and
just kind of progressively hop forward
with that stick two or three five second
stick to create more leg stiffness to
allow you to really get off the ground
right so that that creates the ability
to be resilient in that isometric
position and avoid injury and it's a
great way for people who are training
for a hilly race that might not live in
that area and now we're trained in that
eccentric Landing as well that we get
from downhills that maybe they don't
have so yeah cool yeah yeah
um can we go outside yeah and you're
gonna like put me through the ringer
we're gonna look at here all right
what's cool about this is that people
love these exercises people go I'm not a
runner and you have them do the sticky
hop lunges and you just see that like
they're having fun it's a playful game
yeah yeah
so as you just heard Eric and Chris
share the benefits of adopting exercises
and drills to support running but often
mental endurance is far more challenging
than physical so what do we do when we
feel uninspired to stick to our goals
how can we cultivate lasting motivation
well the trick is to break goals down
into very small actionable steps focus
on running 10 minutes rather than five
miles this is the mindset of my friend
the very exuberant endurance Superstar
hella Sidibe a man who holds a 2 000
plus day running streak he's been
running every single day since May 15
2017 and in this clip hella shares why
achieving your goals starts by making
them pressure free and attainable
so that's when I started taking
responsibility and said go do what you
can do and and and focus on that put
your energy there not the areas you can
and what was that I mean when faced with
the prospect of your professional career
not panning out yeah what's next I
literally told myself one day I'm tired
of making excuses I gotta do something
that I can hold myself accountable for
and then Fitness comes to your mind
you're an athlete and I said hello
whenever you tell yourself you're going
to the gym for a week straight you go
two three days you tap out and I said
what is something that I'm afraid of
running hit me immediately so playing
division one even at the pro level
running I was always afraid of it
um at UMass Amherst the attract team
used to look at us are you guys the
UMass tracking you guys run so much our
coach was very proud of me he rest in
peace Sam Cooke I was very proud to say
you guys are going to be the fittest
team in the country so anything you do
any mistake on the line we want to play
top teams the day before he makes us run
so I was fitness test I was afraid of it
I couldn't sleep the night before I
always play I could play 90 minutes no
problem because with soccer you're
heading 50 50 ball you're attacking your
defending it's not just solely focused
on running so I told my I asked myself
what are you afraid of and Ronnie hit me
and I said you know what I'm gonna go
trace my fear of running let me just go
10 minutes a day for two weeks and zero
pressure it doesn't matter if 10 minutes
mean you don't even get to my last okay
so I told myself that within the first
week I fell in love with it immediately
so I ran to I like Satori as my fiance I
was like I think I can do this for the
rest of my life but I don't want to get
ahead of myself let me do this every day
for a year that's how the whole run
trick started right so it was really
born out of this frustration a little
bit of confusion about what the next
chapter was going to look like yes
exactly exactly that's how it all
started it's also interesting that your
frame on running is through the lens of
punishment yeah when you are on a sports
team it's not run specific it's like
that's you know being told to run is
what happens when you get in trouble
literally you know it's yeah it's like
it's like the stick if you know if it
has two mates of mine I get so stressed
the night before a fitness test they can
see it they're like hell are you okay
I'm like I just can't stop thinking
about that beef test tomorrow morning or
like the Cooper says where you gotta run
two miles under 12 minutes and if you
don't make those time you got to be in
Breakfast Club which is extra Fitness
before the actual practice and the
actual practice has its own Fitness in
it so it really got me all all confused
and scared and petrified but you're
super fit so when you started this
streak I think you said you went out and
ran 10 minutes or something like 10
minutes certainly capable of doing more
than that yeah way capable and in that
10 minutes didn't even last it was just
the first week I was ended up finding
myself running even four miles but the
whole point of that idea I was saying 10
minutes a day was to have zero pressure
because I know if I were to tell myself
hello you gotta run at least five miles
a day that's something at that point in
my mentality and physical ability for
running wasn't I wasn't something I was
kind of capable of of maintaining but I
knew something attainable to the 10
minutes so it was a mental thing so that
made me feel like okay you're doing this
with no pressure enjoying spring in the
year it was May 15th of 2017. so it was
just a perfect amount of time for me to
be out there so that's why yeah I said
10 minutes have a change and and staying
motivated you know what you've done is
so inspirational and I feel like you
do such a good job at communicating
these ideas in a relatable way so for
the people that are watching or
listening who are feeling inspired and
know they need to get off the couch and
do something it doesn't necessarily have
to be a run street but perhaps you know
or in the process of of rethinking their
relationship to their body and
themselves and and the trajectory that
they're on in life like how do you speak
to that person I always say do something
that's pressure free and do something
that's attainable
always those are the biggest factor for
me and pressure free meaning don't do it
because
someone else is doing it do it because
you want to do it and do it on your own
timing don't feel like you got to get it
done if it's a goal whatever you don't
have to get it done in 10 days if you
need a month a month is okay so just do
it pressure free because because of that
I fell in love with running I never
thought there's no chance and now I get
excited to run and I know running is
tough is it has its brutal days but like
I'm so excited to go at it so do it you
don't feel the pressure of maintaining
the streak nope zero pressure and I'd
always say this too this is how I feel
about it the day that I feel like it
becomes more of a pressure and I'm not
liking it I'm gonna stop I'll stop and
then I don't know when that is give
yourself that permission yeah and and I
know I'll find something else I'll find
something else so making sure it's not I
don't have to go I no I don't have to go
run to keep a streak going but I just do
it because it feels good I enjoy it and
I want to keep sharing it so pressure
free do it uh something that's
attainable and just think about even
spending five minutes a day goes a long
way if it's something you love already
or you're thinking about you've been
thinking about that's all the time to
start doing it so if that man just spend
five minutes a day it's about volume
five minutes a day for seven days a week
is gonna add up but if you just do it
today and you take a few days off that's
not it if you can do 10 minutes a day
that's also 10 minutes you can at least
find out on your day if it's important
enough to you so as long as you want to
do it and just pressure free and get
after it and don't think about anybody
even don't compare even if it's running
don't compare yourself to these people
who are doing hundreds of miles these
Fast Pace or these whatever everybody
has their own prices their own journey
and if that's the goal you'll get there
just one day at a time that's it I love
it man yeah one day at a time
I think hella is really spot on when it
comes to comparison it just it doesn't
serve you and it won't get you any
closer to your goals but when you hit
plateaus injuries age-related physical
changes or even postpartum changes it
can be hard to not compare yourself to
others or even to your old self but
Robin arzone wants you to turn these
plateaus into launching pads a global
fitness icon and vice president of
Fitness programming at Peloton Robin
delivers a sermon on positive self-talk
on gratitude pre and postnatal fitness
and how to form a movement routine after
giving birth
how does it work
like speaking strictly about Fitness
like walk me through the prenatal phase
and how you thought about your Fitness
and now postnatal like how you've
approached it whether it's different or
has changed based upon pre Mama peace
pre-strong Mama Robin
prenatal okay so I trained and I taught
five days a week live throughout my
entire pregnancy
only everyone like fell in love with you
because you were like this is like oh
she's pregnant like they there was a
emotional bond I think that you created
with the people that care about you well
I announced the pregnancy on the bike so
that it was like a very major you know
uh pregnancy announcement but that was
that felt very logical to me because I
have shared you know parts of my life
whether it's my romantic Journey or my
you know of course as an athlete and as
a woman as a Latina like there are
aspects of myself that I that I Infuse
into my into my training and my workouts
um and so announcing the pregnancy felt
logical especially because I knew I was
going to teach you know it was hoped to
teach throughout my pregnancy and I've
had a great pregnancy so that was
possible and I you know I continued to
run strength train and cycle throughout
I did
um I got my prenatal certification so I
did prenatal classes as well for Peloton
and that felt
I was like oh I got this postpartum
however that piece of the journey was
daunting
um it felt like
putting myself back together again I
wouldn't I just wasn't used to slowing
down to that extent and being that
vulnerable and having no control I mean
just
there were so many days that the fatigue
was crushing I
um you know I was recovering from a
C-section so you have major abdominal
surgery and there were I mean for
probably the first six weeks I was like
oh my God Am I Ever Gonna Be Moved the
way I'm used to moving
um and the pressure of being this
celebrity Fitness personality and what
if I can't do that again or be that
person that I want to be or know how to
be I had it was
I had I I had real moments of imposter
syndrome especially when you know we
we're run like a network so
I took five months of maternity leave
but when we were planning for me to come
back they're like you know production's
like what do you want to teach you know
we have to put something on the live
schedule for X day I'm like I don't even
physically know what I'm gonna be able
to do you know that felt really intense
and I developed a mantra then
during that postpartum period of
consistency over intensity
because I knew I couldn't go hard in the
paint which is I'm apt to do like that
is much more my flavor of intensity and
I thought just do something every day in
the beginning it was literally breath
work like literally feeding my daughter
and doing 360 diaphragmatic breathing
because I knew that was you know going
to repair my core
that was weeks of that and then it was
walks and you know little by little
amounting to a lot but it was
frustratingly slow and now I'm stronger
than I ever have been you know a year a
year later right
and how much of that did you share
transparently in the Peloton classes
because I feel like
that on some level is much more
relatable to the typical Peloton person
than all the talk about polishing your
crowns and you know all of that kind of
stuff you know what I mean like hey I
don't feel like you know most of the
time I feel like I can barely do
anything and now Robin can speak my
language or I can find a relatability
there that that perhaps even
strengthened your connection with your
community definitely I was I was
super honest especially in those first
few classes about you know in that in
that six-month period my first six
months back on the bike and back in
strength classes
it you know I'd already been doing my
own training before you know during my
maternity leave but it was it's
different it's different during in front
of the camera that for you know those
first few Sprints feel like am I ever
gonna get it back but your body does
remember and I think being honest about
that Journey especially as a woman
um
and very anti-snap back culture you know
I want to talk about that because there
is all this pressure like how quickly
can you get back to where you were
before and your whole thing is about
letting go of what was before and let's
focus on moving forward yeah and I
really
my refrain was what if a plateau is a
launching pad what if a plateau is a
launching pad and for a really long time
um
I still wasn't fitting into you know you
know I like the like I'm supposed to
wear the new Peloton collection and I'd
have to go back and be like I actually
still need this other size you know and
I had to tell my reframe the story
around that and focus on what my body
could do rather than you know what what
size the tag set sure and it's all good
now though feel strong I'm stronger than
ever yeah and I but it was little by
little amounting to a lot I mean it was
truly like
the smallest steps I remember runs on
the West Side Highway just
I trained for the end I read the New
York City marathon
um
about I think Athena was nine months and
I didn't when I tell you that I didn't
look at a watch I would old school like
map the distance from my runs and not
run with a single stitch of like pacing
yeah because I couldn't even I couldn't
even take that information you know I
couldn't be like oh but your pace was
this and then no way I showed up to the
New York City marathon actually having
zero idea how long it was going to take
me like I was just like it's liberating
that way it was so liberating and it was
a night it was
it was a it was a refreshing Back to
Basics like it was like I'm doing this
because I love it and because I I feel
better doing it rather than any external
gaze yeah I shared a little thing about
this on Instagram the other day you know
my version of that is just getting older
and dealing with injuries you know it's
a limited version of of what you
experienced on an extreme level but at
some point the GPS watches and all the
stuff are no longer tools but they're
vehicles to shame yourself right and and
at that point they're counterproductive
and I've been spending more time like
letting go of all of that stuff and what
it does is it it does it does exactly
what you said which is it reminds you
why you're doing it which is that it
brings your yourself Joy you know and
that's really the most important thing
so rather than like looking you know
where am I at it's impossible to look at
that and not immediately measure
yourself against the fittest version of
yourself which is a really unkind unfair
thing to do to yourself it was so I mean
I I noticed myself doing that and I did
do runs on the Pelton tread and it was
thank God I had it because I literally
during nap time like I Cobble I don't
even know how I did cross that finish
line but I cobbled together like I'm
talking like 20 minutes in the morning
20 minutes in the afternoon and that
would be my run you know when I was
supposed to run five miles that day like
it was not
as I would have I would have had done it
in past marathon training Cycles but the
most important Catalyst was not Crossing
that Finish Line it was how I was
talking to myself along the way
um and talk more about that it was um
okay so I'll do so pre-run putting on a
pair of pants that
were bigger than
I have ever trained in before right
go out lace up finish that 10 Mile Run
finish that 13 Mile Run come back kinder
to myself
because I completed what I said I was
gonna do even if it took me
however much longer than previous
versions
and
um
it actually brought me back so I when I
started running after after I was held
hostage and I started and was started
running during Law School
I was it was the first time I was made
aware of my internal conversation of
like the actual thoughts whether it was
like in first person or third person
that were going on in between my ears
and I was
brought back to that in that training
cycle postpartum
as my ability to either use the words
to cat what kind of spell am I going to
cast with the words that are going on
internally and it was either going to be
I had a choice like are you going to
berate yourself for the size of these
pants or are you going to tell yourself
oh my God like you are outside you have
your husband's able to watch the baby
she's healthy like you're healed enough
from this post C-section to even lace up
you know you were craving to even get
Outdoors you know so there was an
element of gratitude and kindness that I
had to incorporate into that training
cycle and it ended up being the best
four months of training of my life yeah
it's a choice right but sometimes it's
hard to make that choice like is there a
mental trick or tactic that you would
deploy to get out of that negative
headspace and and inhabit that more
positive gratitude oriented perspective
yeah I would
all myself what do you have right now
that you used to dream about or pray for
and
in the like specifics it was like just
last week you couldn't even go three
miles so you would have been grateful
that you couldn't even run an hour today
you know
um and
there was yeah that actually is my like
intern that asking myself that question
is like an internal reset like I
I remember in the beginning of the
pandemic during quarantine I was just my
I was pregnant during the pandemic and
it felt the walls felt like they were
closing in at some points you know for
all of us and I started that as a as a
journaling practice but I would force
myself to answer you know what is it
that you used to dream about or wish for
that you have right now but like within
these four walls like and then I noticed
like oh there's that painting that I got
whatever trip or there's you know the
couch that I bought with my husband you
know little things that I was able to
kind of put that gratitude filter on
that it really helps it initially I mean
there of course there were some days and
I was like God this feels cheesy but the
practice of it
um really helped ground me and anchor me
I really agree with Robin when she said
gratitude is integral to motivation and
accepting where you're at in your
movement Journey but oftentimes seasonal
changes can present obstacles when it
comes to movement wintertime weather
makes for cold runs or icy swims who
wants to do that so in this next clip
two-time Olympic swimmer Iron Man master
and my coach Chris Health shares off
season and cold weather routines as well
as discusses how to maximize strength
and Mobility work during the winter
months and how to cultivate consistency
and steady gradual sustained progress
what do you think is the biggest uh
mistake that most
Masters or amateur athletes make around
this time of year well it's the thinking
that you have to keep this perfect
string of workouts going right if you
get 80 of your week done if you get
three four days together strung together
done well and you miss a day that's fine
right we're all not going to be a
hundred percent on any of this I'm never
100 on any of this let alone most of my
athletes life gets in the way right we
all went pro in something other than
this Master's Sports and so not judging
ourselves not worrying too much about
missing a day because the next day
you're going to come back more motivated
more focused as well as fresher and more
recovered and feel better doing it so
don't look for Perfection look for
steady gradual progress
consistency yeah because especially as
Masters athletes as I like to call us
especially as swimmers we remember how
we used to be right and we have this
image when we take on an event whether
it's in Iron Man whether it's a swimming
right space whether it's a running race
how we used to be and how when we had a
lot of time and no kids and not a career
that Demands a lot of us and so forth oh
that's what it felt like that's how I
how I felt and that's how the rhythm of
the training went well that was 20 years
ago but yeah right like you forget and
you have to adjust those expectations
and that's why I always say we can take
on any endurance event we just have to
adjust the expectations however you want
to achieve it we can achieve it but
let's work around what the expectations
are for the endurance athlete out there
how important is the strength work like
time in the gym this time of year well
besides that I will always say it's
individual to the person
strength work is quite important the
beauty of strength work that fits really
well in with the seasons of endurance
training and endurance Athletics is that
this is a great time of year when when
the rain is here the snow is here the
cold temperatures to work on those
things it's again taking advantage of
the environment we're in spending the
next 12 weeks 16 weeks on strength and
Mobility especially Mobility more than
strength and Mobility ties and stability
work what I call chassis Integrity you
know core stability things like that so
that then come the spring we can put a
bigger load on the body when it's time
but yeah I'm a big believer in strength
work not for everybody because what's
are the best use of our limited time
right so some people we do just need to
run right we just need to get them
moving and running or walking in some
cases others we're better off spending
that strength time if they're in the
more temperate climate on the bike right
we can do hill repeats on the bike at a
low Cadence and really work those leg
muscles very similar to squats but
you're doing a very sport specific do
you have a specific Mobility slash
strength slash Core workout that you
recommend people yeah no I sort of fudge
them all together from a variety of
different people that I've worked with
things that I've liked plans that I've
applied and see how they work that's the
that's the fun part right for me even
now at this time of year I'm going
through some different strength work and
versions of strength work that I will
then in two three weeks hand on to my
athletes like some of that kettleball
stuff yeah pedal ball
um a lot of kettlebell I did it again I
had it and I saw her in here
and I got like crucified because I had
Mike Mueller in here who's like an
expert in kettlebells and I was I was
calling him Kettle balls
yes
kettlebells medicine balls dumbbells
um I like all that because again we want
to manage the load and kettlebells
because they're so versatile allow you
you to do a lot of that work and guess
what for 30 bucks on Amazon for 50 bucks
on Amazon you can get a pretty good set
and do most of this stuff in the comfort
of your home 30 minutes and you are
getting huge benefits from that strength
work single leg lunges and squats and
explosive jumps and so forth from from a
leg standpoint core work and
um you know all kinds of crossover work
that you can do with kettlebells that
works really really well yeah all right
well we got to close this
uh episode of Coach's Corner down but
like I want you to just imagine it's
late January it's dark it's cold it's
wet you set that goal at the end of
December but your enthusiasm is starting
to wane what are the key most important
things that people can kind of latch on
to hang their hat on to carry them into
the spring months well you've heard this
from me many times before but there's a
little there's some more tricks to it in
the meantime and that is just doing
something a little something every day
right consistency and don't beat
yourself up if it's only 30 minutes
that's plenty to get the heart rate
going but let's say you're on a
treadmill right or on a trainer bike
trainer where you put your bike on on a
on a resistance trainer like things that
I say to my athletes is you know what
let's say you have the TV on every time
there's a commercial that's when you run
harder you run a two two miles an hour
faster and then when your show comes
back on back to easy right use
everything as in your environment to
your advantage to keep you motivated to
keep it fun save that TV show that you
want to watch on Netflix for
being on the trainer or save that song
Or that music or that podcast or your
podcast for when you're on the treadmill
right and you're stuck in the dark times
or in a gym with a billion people and
you don't really want to interact right
now you just want to Exhale you've had a
long day save that for then to listen to
that music or that new CD or CD CD yeah
how old are you exactly what
um or a podcast right and so again use
those things to your advantage to get
you out there every day the other thing
that I use and my athletes know this is
I put out an index card when I go
through hard times every night and I put
it right by my coffee in the morning so
that index card has my workouts for the
day on it and just seeing that index
card there with a few intentions I mean
it's not big you know it's a small
little index cards lying there and
seeing it first thing in the morning
when I'm tired and sleepy and walking
turn on the water you know already okay
well that I can do
right it's just that index card I have
to put that in a box at the end of the
day at some point today I want to get
that done right I like that another
little trick that I use
is to prepare for the the following
day's workout the evening before by
doing simple things like okay it's a run
so I'll pull out the shorts and the
socks and like kind of get everything
ready and organized to make it as easy
as possible to begin that workout the
next day and I think just the simple Act
of organizing that creates
an emotional investment that makes it
harder for you the next day to not do it
or have it with you like you have it in
your car with you at all times but I
also like to do the you know the
podcasts are really intriguing right
because you see what the topics are and
you load them the night before and you
look forward you create your playlist
exactly and you look forward oh I'm
curious as to what this guy has to say
or what she is contributing right I like
this one this one's only 30 minutes
though so I got to make sure I have I
know it's going to follow that so I
don't have to stop and yeah well but we
all also know once that initial momentum
happens you're out the door you're going
right no I mean not that but like I I
don't want to have to stop my workout to
hit play on the next thing like I Want
It All cued so it'll just flow right
yeah yeah get in a little something
every day don't try to string together
too many days perfectly in a row just
look at yourself big picture A lot of
times I also say where do you want to be
on January 31st nothing crazy easy not
something for June yet how do I want to
feel January 31st how do I want to feel
February 28th or whatever it will be
this year so give yourself short-term
outcomes that you say okay that I can
achieve I just need to be a little bit
better at the end of January than I was
at the end of December right and then
you're making progress so that you can
set the marker for next month out there
but this is what I want to achieve right
you can chart it you can there's a lot
of ways to keep you excited about the
next week but if you have short-term
goals that you feel good about achieving
it'll just create momentum once again
if you can Master just a little bit of
movement every single day it can really
have a dramatic difference in not just
your physical health but also your
mental health but tying in more natural
movements throughout your day that's
even better so closing out our movement
master class is natural lifestyle coach
and Barefoot ultra running Phenom Tony
riddle who is going to distill down
everything we've covered today to the
basics by sharing how to turn daily
Mobility exercises into habits as well
as talking about how to nourish
flexibility and mobility and why we all
might actually need to relearn how to
walk
so if you were going to pull out a
prescription pad and write a
prescription for me short of getting rid
of all the chairs in my house and
knowing me as a runner and a multi-sport
athlete what is the prescription around
squatting or other things that I could
be doing or somebody who is like me
could be doing
um and as many people like you I get to
see a lot of people I um I wouldn't I
wouldn't go as extreme to taking your
furniture away it would be too much
don't worry it's not your family
wouldn't handle it it'd be too much of
an emotional might be into it I don't
know
um I think again you have to take it
back to so after a certain amount of
time like after this immediately after
I'd be taking things to the ground again
just because the length of time you're
sat here
um I feel bad that we're not sitting on
the ground again we can squat after
that's the beauty of it like I I was on
a flight for 11 and a half hours right
and I'd get up I'd get up regularly go
to the back of the plane do the mobility
sequence open my hips up do some
shoulder Mobility squat
you know I saw that on Instagram and I
hope you had an aisle seat and then I'd
go back to the seat no I managed to get
an extra leg room and I had a window
seat oh you did so did you have to climb
over somebody every time you wanted to
get up every 20 minutes yeah and I was
like explaining earlier the lady next to
me is really demonstrating the you know
the behavior that has encouraged me even
more I was like oh wow she's
so um yeah I would I would again just
look at what you're doing within the
environment and try and make small
changes within it rather than add too
much to your day and I think that's
where a lot of things fall down is we
think oh where am I going to find the
time to do that so it's very simple to
be able to slide a chair away hold the
edge of the desk do a few squats lifting
your chest up and use the desk as an
anterior support a lot of people I see
don't just don't have the ankle function
ankle Mobility to perform a squat so
allow the heel to come up and just keep
the shape and just drop onto your
launches so it's almost like a straight
body your butt will be resting on your
heel and your knees will be forward
you just do a few Rhythm little bounces
in that position then stand again and
then you're ready to walk
um other disciplines that we're gonna we
will cover just go through a few
kneeling positions that you can do on
the ground and a little Mobility
sequence that you can play with within
that and again they're just rest
positions like long sits or straddle
sits and things like that the other
thing for the upper body is I recommend
for everyone to do is is put a bar up to
hang off so
um hanging is even more ancient if you
think than running right so it goes back
into what would be our primate
foundation so if we go right down climb
down that phylogenic tree we get to the
brachiating Apes to how to restore and
open up the rib cage and open up the
lungs would be to basically just hang
simple hanging systems so so you go
through different hanging positions and
we have in the wrist the elbow the
shoulder and your scapula your shoulder
blade we have all the same braking
brachiating abilities as all the other
Apes
um and and I find people just some
people have trouble changing light bulbs
now so it's really important to just
keep nourishing that 80 shoulder
injuries I'd say is through the lack of
brachiation and then we try and do
things like dips in the gym but the
scapular is internally rotated and
raised then again it's just blowing up
the shoulder so hanging will help reset
all straight arm strength forget about
bent arm strength forget about pulling
patterns
just get used to being completely
straight in the arm then you'll posture
hang from it again that will help
mobilize the shoulder but it will also
open up the tendons the ligaments
everything and even the arteries through
that pathway you'll lift your rib cage
which will then make your breathing
clearer and then you can play once
you're in that position you can start to
go through active hangs so trying to
keep your arms straight whilst lifting
your chest up into your hands so there's
no Bend in the elbow and that starts to
strengthen the lower trapezius which is
in the mid back a lot of the disciplines
that we see are about mobilization and
flexibility and you can do all the
flexibility training you like you can do
amazing work for the mid back but if you
don't have the strength to hold it there
through the lower trapezius gravity is
going to take over
what about doing pull-ups and chin-ups
and those are pulling but great but on a
um straight arm strength to begin with
so there's Edo
portals work yeah so here's a here's
like a hanging tutorial thing
um and I would I would suggest that you
basically set a timer so you can have a
time I work with clients they start
might start with 10 minutes hanging um
10 seconds hanging and then they're off
the bar and then I give them 30 seconds
rest then they go back up and then that
goes to then that will turn to 20
seconds 30 seconds and a minute
and the way this this then starts to
unravel is you start to build a
relationship it becomes a new habit so
I'll give you an example of someone who
I coach who's 78 is a old guy called you
hoodie
um he rocked up at my gym door when he
was 72 so six years ago
and he was completely stooped scrunched
up old posture
um he brought natural birthing into the
UK wrote a book called birth and Beyond
real manual for childbirth amazing guy
um but gravity and age were taking over
them and so where you want to learn how
to walk and I was like okay so it's a
good place let's get you off on the
treadmill and so at the age of 72 you
want to learn how to walk so I interest
him right so a lot of people up he went
on the treadmill I just recorded him
showed him as possible oh my God I can't
believe I looked like that you know like
oh bent over and these are these boxes
that I was introduced by a coach called
Lee and basically like the it's the
conscious competency model so I show
them the video and up until sorry I've
recorded them up until that point
they're unconsciously incompetent
and I showed in the video and now
they're consciously incompetent and then
I go through the drills they need and
then they become consciously competent
and then over time doing the same drills
and the same method which we're going
what you're wanting to break down what
would I do that then becomes
unconsciously
um competent and that's how you learn
the skill but remembering the next time
you get recorded you'll still be
unconsciously incompetent so you keep
feeding that so he he basically just
wanted to learn how to walk we go
through walking go through that model
with him
um and I prescribe footwork for
rewilding the feet how to get the feet
in the foot shape rather than the shoe
shape so his feet were compromised by 72
years of inappropriate Footwear that
were compromising the shape of the foot
get that back then ground rest positions
so we then went through the various
different ground positions what I would
prescribed for him and then hanging and
that was it and then he had a hanging
bar in his home so this guy now since
then has climbed Everest Base Camp
Bhutan
Mount Kenya Atlas Mountains
um
and
and basically this is his morning
routine so he wakes up now in an air
purified room
trots downstairs gets to the office on
the second floor hangs on the bar goes
into the office gets on the map does his
Mobility sequence has a standing desk
answers his emails go downstairs prep
his smoothie prebiotics probiotic
symbiotics puts his vivos on walks down
to the tube gets to the tube it doors
open he gets on people usually say
because he's 78 would you like to see
he's like nah I'm okay and up he goes He
hangs on the bar so he hangs on the bars
while the tube's moving feet off the
floor tube stops doors open right next
one next time the doors closed any
squats any squats and then he does
breath work so he does between breath
work hanging squatting and a bit of
Surfing so surfing you don't hold on to
anything you just try and get your
support on the train
and that's at the age of 78 and he just
made small changes all the way along and
is using his commute he's incredible
shape now Wow and his spine straightened
out straight to now it's completely
upright wow but looks like the
difference is it's hell yeah how he
looks now so he doesn't look like the 72
year old he looks you know he looks
great he looks in amazing shape and he's
a newfound confidence within it it's
kind of a beautiful Act of humility to
walk into your gym and say teach me how
to walk too I think that that takes
courage most people wouldn't do that
and it's interesting to think about
walking as something that we might have
to learn or relearn like we were talking
about this in the context of running
like Born to Run we're all born Runners
we don't think that we need any
instruction it's all instinctual and
intuitive and I suppose on some level it
is but through the means by which we
live our lives in this Western
industrialized Society
we've reshaped our bodies that have now
created a situation in which we probably
do need to formally learn how to run and
you just pointed out to me when we were
on the trail like all these things that
I'm not doing correctly that I could be
doing better because I'm unconsciously
incompetent in certain aspects of what I
do even though I've been doing it for a
long time and I've done it at a decent
level yeah man
a really decent level
but there's still so much to learn you
know and I know and I know I know that
I'm not you know working at my capacity
because I've never had anybody formally
instruct me in anything
okay so if you're in an office and you
your HR department won't allow you to
have a standing desk
again you slide your chair away you do
some squats I have a whole squat
tutorial that we can we can send out to
the listeners as well yeah it's great
like uh I'll put a link in the show so
we can do that and then that gives you
some tips as well with what you can be
doing behind the desk
um
10 000 steps everyone loved banging on
about 10 000 steps but for me if you
have 10 000 poor steps that might lead
you to an injury it's probably not the
best model
um if you're wearing compromised
Footwear with a dodgy heel and a pointed
toe box it's not the best model
so I would go most people are wearing
those kind of shoes yeah I would cut
back and just say okay what's the more
natural environment for a foot it's
nature it's creating a foot-shaped shoe
so go to minimal Footwear there's some
amazing Brands out there vivo's one but
there's others there's some Primal um
office wear that's come through and it's
trying to basically even get into the
feeling that it's not about running in
those shoes it's about living in those
shoes and that will give you a great
amazing foundation so if you're into all
your disciplines it could be Pilates
yoga it could be running what we're
talking about and it will only enhance
that those disciplines will just get
better because you'll be moving in the
appropriate systems and creating the
right muscle action tendon actions for
them which means the next day you can
get up and do the same thing without the
tension
all right everybody that's it we did it
this master class was packed with uh
just an absolute battery of resources to
spark to sustain and and to fully adopt
movement and Mobility practices that are
useful and most importantly meaningful
to you but the biggest lesson I took
away from compiling this very special
episode is that physically embodying a
dream a vision a belief or a purpose
through movement is really the only way
that you can and will ever make a change
because as I say relentlessly on this
show mood follows action you cannot
think your way into anything you can
only do something about it I truly
believe movement isn't just a physical
practice that benefits the body it's
actually a means of evolution because
when we Embrace movement even in the
smallest ways we open the door to a
world of possibilities in my case a walk
led to a run which led to ultra
endurance racing and ultimately to this
entirely New Life altogether so my hope
is that this master class gives you the
education and the inspiration and the
tools that you need to adopt a form of
movement that brings you Joy a Mobility
routine that nourishes your body and
that you discover something new about
yourself your purpose and your meaning
along the way
quick reminder that links to the full
episodes for each of the individuals
excerpted today can be found in the show
notes at ritual.com and in closing keep
moving more exploring more joy and of
course always more plants
but namaste
[Music]